How many bakers are left? Nine.
But we had nine last week.
We WOULD have had nine last week,
but one was sick,
but he's returned, so we're back up
to nine. But we send someone home
every week, so that would take us
down to seven,
and with a baker coming back,
that would be eight.
Except Paul and Prue went rogue
last week
and didn't send anybody home.
So, there'll eight next week?
No, no, cos we're sending
two people home this week,
and two from nine is seven.
So, are you clear?
Yeah. Let's start the show.
TOGETHER: Welcome to
The Great British Bake Off.
So, will there ever be eight?
I've got some great eight jokes.
Like what? Why is eight scared
of seven? Don't know.
Because seven ATE nine!
Oh, that is good. That's a loss!
Got to get that in. Yeah.
Maybe I could speak to the producer.
What's he like? I don't know,
I've never met him.
Last time...
Roll, baby, roll!
..desserts were on the menu...
Look how lovely that looks.
What can I say? It's called talent.
..with a Hollywood handshake
and a peach of a Showstopper.
ALL: Yeah!
Bravo!
Dan was crowned Star Baker.
APPLAUSE
Karen... This is so rubbish.
..and Briony...
It's going, it's going!
..collapsed under pressure.
You've got to laugh about
these things.
And cry a little bit. I'm all right!
But with Terry ill,
they were let off the hook.
The person going home is...
..nobody.
THEY GASP
You...!
RUBY LAUGHS
This week... Right, here we go.
..things get spicy.
Smells really good.
It's a sticky Signature Challenge...
Why does he look wonky?
..a doubly exotic Technical...
Oh, my goodness me. They've melted!
..and the Showstopper
leaves everyone hanging...
It's going to be really tight.
..as two bakers...
Come on, come on, come on, come on!
..are set to leave...
Oh, God, I'm shaking! Ohh!
..The Great British Bake Off.
Uh-oh! Crack on. Unbelievable!
Crack on. How did I do that?!
For subtitling services, contatct:
waqas.zahoor89@gmail.com
IN FRENCH:
I'm just excited about Spice Week.
Last week, I was not well at all,
so to come back today,
it's a lovely feeling,
and whatever happens,
at least I'll stay or go on merit,
rather than on something
out of the ordinary.
Two people go this week,
which is on everyone's mind.
So, the odds are high.
If I were a cat, I was maybe down
to maybe four lives, maybe less.
I just don't know.
Maybe three, and we'll see how
these three challenges go!
Hello, bakers, and for the very
first time in Bake Off history,
we are lost in spice!
For your Signature Challenge today,
Paul and Prue would love you
to make a ginger cake.
Your ginger cake can be made using
any form of ginger that you choose -
fresh, dried, stem, syrup.
You can use
complementary flavours...
But ginger must be
the dominant flavour.
You knew that? I did know that. Yup.
Your ginger cake needs to be a
suitable size for a family tea-time.
I didn't know that.
You have two hours
to make your ginger cake.
On your marks... Get set... Bake!
PRUE: Ginger is my
favourite spice,
and we are looking for
a ginger cake.
It's about finding that balance
of heat, spice, flavour, warmth.
I mean, if you want a sort of
fudgy, sticky kind of cake,
then stem ginger would be good.
It's a mistake to think the answer
is to use fresh ginger.
If ginger stays in the oven
for a very long time,
it loses its flavour.
Ginger does complement well
with a lime or a lemon,
but you've got to find those levels
where ginger is still that gorgeous
flavour that comes pouring through.
Good morning. Hello!
Hello, Briony. Hello.
What's going on here, then?
Right, so, I am making
a honey and apricot ginger cake.
OK.
Is it a particular honey?
Bee honey! It's honey from bees.
Wow, there's nothing you don't know,
is there, Paul?
THEY LAUGH
Briony's honey and ginger sponges
will be decorated
with dark chocolate ganache
and honeycomb,
and filled with an apricot jam.
Where's the ginger?
There's fresh ginger
and ground ginger in the sponge.
I'm going to have honey buttercream
icing. Any ginger in there? Um, no.
Have you got any ginger in
the apricots? No, I haven't.
She's just got ginger in the cake.
Oh, have I missed a trick here?
Good luck, Briony. Thank you.
I think Paul was a bit worried
that there wasn't quite
enough ginger, maybe.
But, you know,
there's ginger in the cake.
The foundation of a deliciously
sticky ginger cake
is a liquid mix of fats,
sugars and syrups.
HONEY BOTTLE SQUELCHES
KAREN: Excuse you!
I didn't like to say anything.
Bit nervous!
Basically,
it's going to give this gooey...
..gooeyness of the ginger cake.
But unless the mix
is warmed gently...
OK.
..the milk and eggs will split...
DAN: Oh, God, just melt!
..and the batter will be ruined
before the ginger has even
been introduced.
Butter, treacle, golden syrup,
eggs are about to go in,
and something else.
Milk, milk!
I knew there was something else.
So, it's just like the sort of
sticky, heavy ginger cakes
like my mother used to make for me
when I was a kid.
Dan is recreating his mum's
recipe four times
for a towering ginger cake
filled with lemon Swiss meringue
buttercream.
Come on!
I'm just trying to get my cakes in
the oven as quickly as possible.
They'll be quite deep
and they'll need
as long to cool as possible
before I start assembling.
These cakes will probably
end up in the freezer!
Now the wet ingredients need to be
carefully combined with the dry...
Quite a strong ginger taste,
I would say!
..and whilst all of the bakers
are adding ground ginger...
Nobody's going to say they can't
get my... ginger!
..to guarantee the dominant ginger
kick the judges are looking for...
I'm getting me chopper out!
..some are going further.
I am using crystallised ginger.
I'm putting in stem ginger.
I love the ginger flavour,
so I always just keep adding
more and more all the time.
PRUE: What is the ginger
in the cake?
Dry ginger, as well as
chopped stem ginger.
When I tell my mum, she was quite
surprised at why people
would have ginger in a cake, because
in India, we normally use ginger
for savoury things, we cook curries
and stuff with it,
so she was quite surprised.
Rahul's mum has never tried
his triple-layered ginger and
caramel cake with cinder toffee,
inspired by a very
British tradition.
The first time I had ginger cake is
during a Bonfire Night celebration.
Did you like it the first time
you tried it? Yeah.
I didn't really think these
flavours can actually work,
because in India,
sweet things means extremely sweet.
So, this is like a learning curve
for me, so I'm learning.
Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. Cheers.
Rahul is not the only baker hoping
for fireworks in Spice Week.
KAREN: When I was a kid, Bonfire
Night was a big annual gathering,
and all the neighbours
brought something,
ginger cake being one of them,
or parkin.
Karen is updating a traditional
Yorkshire parkin,
with crystallised ginger
and cinder toffee,
and to warm everyone up
on Bonfire Night,
there's brandy in the sponge
and the cream cheese frosting.
You know who's going
to like brandy, don't you? Prue?
Prue, yeah. She loves a bit
of brandy. In the bag, then!
She's got a hip flask.
I have to keep it topped up.
Is that your job?
Yeah, it's a big job as well!
Prue and Karen won't be drinking
alone.
Even in general cakes, I love
putting rum into the cake batter.
It just tastes so good.
Why bother baking if you can't
make it boozy?
Ruby's adults-only Jamaica ginger
cake will have even more rum
in her piped cream decoration,
but the booze should be balanced
with a triple hit of ginger.
I've got some stem ginger
and ground ginger going in there,
then I'm using the stem ginger syrup
to drench it as well.
So after all that, if it still
doesn't taste of ginger, I give up!
For her ginger cake batter...
Ow! I got some ginger in my eye!
..Manon's taking a fresh approach.
It smells really good.
I use ginger when I cook Asian food,
and I've always used the fresh one.
You just really have the essence
of the ginger.
Manon's sponge will be coated
in a lemon and ginger
Italian Meringue buttercream,
and there's fresh ginger in her
lemon curd filling as well as
her sponge better.
Is lemon curd something they have
in France,
or is it a very British thing?
Not really, no.
Even ginger cake is not really
a thing that we do.
Have you practised this?
A little bit.
You haven't, have you?
This week was quite busy at work,
so I'm improvising a little bit.
Just a bit worried that my cake
batter is a bit runnier than normal.
The higher liquid content in
a ginger cake batter can make
baking times unpredictable.
I should have put 40ml of milk
in with the eggs.
I didn't put any milk in,
I've put 40ml of brandy in.
Right, here they go.
Just a few minutes can be
the difference between a cake
that's deliciously sticky...
165 for 50 minutes. Low and slow.
..and one that's dense and claggy.
Do your thing!
RAHUL: Going in for 25 minutes.
Oops!
But the perfect baking time...
What's going on?
..could be the least
of Dan's worries.
What the hell is that?
It looks like cheese!
Dan's batter has split.
That's literally never
happened before, ever.
Hello, Dan. How's it going?
Oh, mate, I am a hot mess.
You're a hot mess? Why?
I don't know what happened.
I ended up with, like, lumps
of cheese in my cake batter.
Yeah, I know, I don't understand
what the hell happened!
Well, I don't know anything about
baking, so I can't help you,
but that doesn't sound good. I'm
assuming the milk got overheated.
I mean, I don't know how I would
have made curds in my cake batter.
What sort of milk is it -
breastmilk?!
Yum, yum, yum! That's what
lemon curd should look like.
And then I'm going to start
making the meringue...
While most of the other bakers
move on...
I'm just making
my caramel buttercream.
..Dan has a crucial decision
to make.
I'm making brandy Alexander
cream cheese frosting.
So, I'm making my jam.
These are dried apricots that have
been soaked in water overnight.
I'm going to have to start again.
I don't really have any choice.
HE SIGHS
I'm actually screwed now.
That's half an hour gone
and I'm back to zero.
Curse of the Star Baker!
But he's not the only baker who had
to get a sponge in the oven.
# Take good care of me
# I don't want your love
any more...#
I'm making a caramelised
pear and ginger cake,
like an upside-down cake.
I'm just letting the caramel cool
in the tins now with the pears in,
then the batter will go on top.
Terry's caramelised pears will sit
on top of two ground and
stem ginger sponges, which will be
sandwiched and decorated with
a vanilla cream and cheese frosting.
The batter looks
the right consistency.
It's quite a slow bake, so I need to
get it in the oven quickly enough
so that it can cool
to put the cream cheese on.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
Oh, kill me now!
I wasn't in shot then, was I?
Just get those in... There we go.
Whilst Terry and Dan finally
begin baking...
Right, no cheese this time!
Still got so much to do.
..everyone else's dilemma
is when to stop.
Do you smell the ginger?
Smells good!
Every minute fresh ginger spends
in the heat of the oven...
Okey dokey.
..it loses flavour.
Just so nervous about
undercooking them.
Tick-tick!
But stem ginger will
release moisture...
Should be all right.
..which can drastically increase
how long it takes to bake.
It's a bit of a nervy time, just
waiting for the cake to come out.
OK, so they can come out
and start cooling.
If they're not cool,
you can't get the frosting on,
cos it just melts, then it's a mess.
If that wasn't enough
to worry about...
So, we've got the caramel here,
and we've got the pears
poaching here,
and I'm making biscuits over here.
Kim-Joy won't just be baking cakes.
It's my little gingerbread house.
I really like, um, miniature things.
The smallest gingerbread house
Bake Off has ever seen
will sit atop
crystallised ginger sponge
with cream cheese frosting
and salted caramel drizzle.
Ginger is homely, and it makes me
think of being at home.
You can picture yourself
in the house.
And there's pears in the background,
and they're kind of like trees.
Yeah.
For his decoration,
Jon is also thinking of home.
Well, they're my kids.
That'll be Hannah and that'll be
Lucy, that's James and Emily.
Look at Hannah! There's me.
Hello, Hannah.
Ooh, I dropped Hannah on her side!
That's the one thing I do know
about children -
don't drop them on their...
Yeah, that's the tip,
don't drop your kids! Good luck.
See you later, mate.
I need him at times, don't I?
Jon's gingerbread family will live
on top of a stem ginger sponge
with Italian meringue buttercream,
and he's planning to surround
Hannah and the gang
with a touch of bling!
That's my lemon, water
and agave solution,
which will be dripped into my oil
to create my lemon tiny balls.
The whole thing sort of forms
a jelly, it melts in your mouth.
And I hope they go all right,
because I can't afford
for anything to go wrong.
Especially when there could be
two going out this week.
So, no time to relax and have a cup
of tea or anything, you know.
45 minutes remaining.
Come on, cake!
I want to get the dome tops
off them,
then I'm going to get them
chilled in the fridge.
Da-daah! They're ready for out.
Ow!
They're going straight
in the freezer.
They're not thoroughly cooled,
but I don't want to risk the time.
It's important to get it level.
Kind of just got to get it on,
as well.
Look at this tiny house!
Is that Sandi's house?
It could be, yeah!
Could be Sandi's house.
Why does he look wonky?
It's gone suddenly very hot in here!
They're still really hot.
Bakers... You have ten minutes
remaining.
You can do this. We believe in you!
Some of you.
Time to get started, then, isn't it?
I can't assemble until that's cool.
That's just going to melt
the cream cheese.
No, don't eat...
Noel! Did you eat any? No!
Still too hot.
Going to have to go for it
and put it in the fridge, I think.
Come on!
It's so unstable. It's terrifying!
Bakers, you've got
one minute left. 60 seconds!
It's sliding everywhere. Too hot.
It's gone a bit...
Bakers, your time is up!
Please place your ginger cakes
at the end of your work stations.
Oh! I give up.
That's a proper drip cake.
That's what you need...
You're wobbling it! You're wobbling
the floor! I want to taste. No!
You're wobbling the floor.
Jon, it's seriously
going to collapse. Don't!
The bakers' Signature ginger cakes
are about to face
Spice Week's first judging.
Hi, Jon. Hello. Right, Jon.
A very concise little cake.
The little balls on the top look
quite cute. Nicely executed.
That's his family
you're just mutilating!
It's a LITTLE claggy.
A little too...
But the flavour...
When you do hit one
of the little lemon gels,
it's beautiful because you've got
a lovely blend between the two.
And they were surprising, I've never
had those little lemon goldy balls.
They're so good. Oh, cheers.
It's quite a hard cake, that.
I put some, um... Oh, Karen.
No? Too much booze. Too much booze.
Too much booze.
I've never heard Prue say
"too boozy".
I know. I never thought
I'd hear me say that either!
Well, thank you... Thank you.
..for your appraisal of that.
The colours are beautiful.
They look very pretty.
The drizzle looks great as well.
You get the rum.
Yeah. It's delicious. Good.
The rum is the overwhelming flavour,
but it ain't no ginger cake, for
sure. Oh, really?
I think it looks amazing. Thank you.
Your pipework is very good.
It's very pleasing to look at.
It's lovely.
Mmm. Lovely and gingery.
Good texture.
You, my friend, are a little genius,
aren't you?
Because you surprise me every week.
Every week.
The sponge is perfect.
The stem ginger is awesome.
I mean, I have never liked
honeycomb.
With ginger in it, it's lovely. You
are one hell of a baker. Well done.
Thank you. Amazing. Thank you.
Yes! I told ya!
Quite annoying, really.
Sorry? You've made him angry. Why?
Said it was too good. Sorry.
It looks quite impressive.
It's a lovely-looking cake.
Nice, shiny chocolate.
It's very dry. Oh. It didn't taste
very gingery or very sweet.
The apricot tends to overwhelm it.
To be honest,
apricot and the ginger together
doesn't necessarily work.
OK.
It looks a mess.
I think it is down to the
temperature of the cake.
Interesting texture.
It's very gluey. And the ginger's
not overwhelming either.
It's definitely a winter one
with loads of custard, for sure.
Which ironically is what it looks
like. Yeah, it is!
The gingerbread house
looks incredible.
The attention to detail
looks fantastic.
That is the most beautiful-textured
cake. Ah!
The flavour from the ginger
in the powder is beautifully
balanced and it's got a nice warmth
that comes through.
That is, um... It's good.
..beautiful.
Ah! Thank you! Well done, Kim!
Got such sweaty hands!
Thank you so much.
Well done, Kim-Joy. Wonderful.
Thank you.
Well, obviously there's an issue
to the lean. Yep.
The Leaning Tower of Ginger.
But I think it comes down to timing
because the sponge is
probably still too warm.
It's gone more and more condensed.
So, as you start at the top,
it's lighter, slightly less so,
slightly more dense. And very.
And then dense.
It's such a pity because being
too warm when you were putting it
together has affected everything.
Very elegant-looking cake.
Very elegant.
And a little touch of chocolate.
Again, you blowtorched it.
Nicely done.
Ooh, it got a bit all together.
Such a rich colour in there.
Certainly get the ginger
and the lemon.
It's so beautiful,
how soft the sponge is.
And because the lemon curd is
so strong, the Italian meringue
makes it less so.
Yeah, it's one of the best
ginger cakes I've had for some time.
Yay!
Thank you.
Can I have one, Prue, too?
That actually reminds me
of my nan's cake,
which is full of ginger,
but it's the bake.
It's so good. Thank you so much.
Thank you. Great job, Manon.
So happy. Got a handshake.
And a Prue pat as well.
Kim-Joy...
I got a handshake!
In my head I was like,
"This is really cool.
"I hope they think it's cool."
And they thought it was cool.
Are you happy? Yeah, yeah.
I'm trying. You're trying.
I'll probably give the recipe to
my mum, so that she can make it.
I'm not sure whether they will like
it or not.
You don't want it to look like you
don't know what you're doing.
I just need to be safe. There's no
reason why I can't still be safe.
Spice Week's Technical Challenge
is twice as mysterious as any of
the bakers have faced before.
We've got this.
Now, your Technical Challenge
today has been set for you by Paul.
Paul, any words of advice or wisdom?
This challenge is all about
delicate baking.
That can't be it?
That's it. As ever,
it's judged blind
so I'm going to ask you two lovelies
to leave the tent.
They're going to go
and play Fortnite.
What? It's an online survival game.
It's not going well.
Prue keeps killing Paul. Oh, OK.
Anyway, for your
Technical Challenge,
Paul would like you to make
two batches of six ma'amoul.
Come again? Ma'amoul - you know,
the delicious ancient pastries
from the Middle East.
One batch must be filled with
walnuts and shaped with a mould.
The other batch must be filled
with a date paste and must be
decorated by pinching the dough
with ma'amoul tongs.
There you go.
Never before have I known less
about what I'm saying right now.
You've got an hour and a half.
On your marks... Get set... Bake.
Ma-mool? Ma'amoul. Ma'amoul.
Ma'amoul? I don't know
what a ma'amoul is.
No idea what they look like.
No idea what they taste like.
So whatever I make,
I'll be happy with. I hope!
Paul, I'm really ashamed to say that
I have never heard of ma'amoul.
What are they?
Traditionally,
it's Middle Eastern pastry,
eaten at the end of Ramadan,
and it's really celebratory.
So you have two different types
here. You have the date
and you have the walnut.
They're so beautiful.
So we've got some pretty punchy
flavours going on inside these.
We have mastic,
basically a resin,
and it smells a little bit
like aniseed.
Now, this is mahlab.
This is the seed that sits inside
the cherry kernel, but as soon as
you grind them down, this becomes
a very potent flavour.
It's quite like almonds
and cherries at once. Yes.
These two spices are in the pastry
itself. It sounds wonderful.
The tricky part is, actually,
you want definition on the pastry.
Now, overhandle it,
it becomes too rubbery,
becomes too oily and you're
going to lose it.
If we start with the walnut.
It's really lovely.
It's very, very delicate. That's the
orange blossom and the cardamom.
But in the date one,
it's a little bit more pungent.
You have cinnamon in there,
you have rose water in there.
So there's so many big, big
flavours they've got
to be careful of. Are we telling
the bakers how much to put in?
We are for the dough, but not for
the filling. You are unkind, Paul!
So we've got, for the dough,
"Put the mastic in a mortar with one
"teaspoon of the sugar
and grind to a powder."
I've never cooked
with mastic before.
I don't really know what it tastes
like. Well, I've come across mastic.
It's an ingredient in tsoureki,
the Greek bread.
"Combine with the remaining
dry ingredients."
"Add the ghee and rub together to
form a breadcrumb consistency."
Tablespoon of orange blossom.
Tablespoon of rose water.
Exactimondo. In there.
And then knead until smooth.
Oh, very, very crumbly.
What does it look like?
What, the thing? Yeah, what is it?
I have no idea.
I'll tell you, at no point did Noel
and I know what we were saying.
At no point.
So you don't know either? No.
I've absolutely... I'm looking
forward to seeing them. OK.
Jolly good. So the recipe says,
"Knead until smooth." I've kneaded.
It's pretty smooth. So I'm now going
to make the date filling.
Rose water. Ground cinnamon.
Mahlab.
There's no, like, quantities.
It's a guessing game.
Quite fun.
That's the mahlab.
Wow. How much do I add in?
I'll start little and then add.
You don't want to overload it.
I'm putting one quarter
of a teaspoon.
It doesn't say how much rose water.
It's very fragrant.
It doesn't smell unpleasant.
Quite nice.
Middle Eastern food,
it's to do with the softness.
It's not fire cracking.
It's got a lot of rose in it.
I'm going to put some more
spices in there.
But the date and mahlab filling
is only half the story.
Walnuts, hello.
Where are you? There.
Walnuts, golden raisins,
orange blossom honey
and some ground cardamom.
It's a funny flavour, cardamom,
it can overpower things.
It'll be fine. I'm tasting it
as I'm making the filling.
Wow. How perfect,
you're back to make ma'amoul.
Just the thing you'd hoped for!
Just...
Yeah, just what I was dreaming of.
"I know what I want -
ancient pastry from the Middle East,
"that's the one for me."
That's much better.
Bakers, you have one hour left
to finish your ma'amoul.
"Flatten each ball of dough
in the palm of your hand
"to form a little cup." Right.
So crumbly, though, this pastry.
So it kind of just falls
apart in your hands.
"Fill six of the pastry cups
with a ball of the date filling
"and the remaining six pastry cups
with a ball
"of the walnut filling, and seal."
Interesting.
And by interesting I mean awful.
Is that sealed?
Hello. How are you doing?
Look at your stance.
I'm loving this, it's like...
What are you trying to do,
put a walnut in your casing?
I have no idea!
Ah, that's why you don't handle it
long, the ghee becomes wet again.
"To shape,
press the walnut-filled balls
"into the flower-shaped mould."
Ah.
These are definitely walnuts.
So these need to go in
the flower-shaped mould.
It seems like a terrible idea but,
all right.
So I guess the date filling.
That's the date filling.
Please work.
Oh!
I'm trying to get it out
the mould but I can't get it out.
There you go.
Oh, love, yours look really tidy.
They do look nice.
I'm happy with these.
Oh, that doesn't work.
Guess what? I've done the wrong
thing in the wrong mould.
I can't do anything about that now.
You can't... Don't worry, just...
Uh-oh. ..crack on.
Unbelievable! Crack on.
How did I do that?!
"For the date filling, shape the
remaining six pastry into balls.
"Use the ma'amoul tongs."
What are they?
Hello. Oh, hello.
You have your ma'amoul tongs.
Tiny robot arms clapping.
THEY SCREECH
Hey, Briony's made a cake.
HE SCREECHES
"Pinch the pastry to make
six identical designs."
I really don't know what I'm looking
for here.
It says, "Do a ball."
I think I'm just going to go
with this.
Something like that.
It's just a really short pastry.
Very delicate.
Hopefully the impression
will stay in when it's baked.
BAAING
Bakers, you've got
half an hour left!
That was very good. I know. Quick!
Going in.
OK, I'm just going
to put it in.
And now you just hope for the best.
It's more like biscuit
than pastry, really.
So I don't think
it'll take too long.
I'll check on them in 10 minutes.
Erm, 20 minutes?
If you need me, I'll be down here.
The problem is
I don't know what I'm looking for.
I'm going to open my oven.
They look beautiful.
These ones are opening.
Who blooming knows?
I might put it a tiny bit more.
You don't want them to be dark.
It looks like the pastry's
actually melting.
You know what?
I might take mine out.
I've increased the temperature.
They really don't look any different
from, like, when you put them in!
They've got to cool, though,
haven't they?
I think they're going to have
to come out, you know.
They're coming out, no matter what.
Oh, my goodness me, they've melted!
It's a disaster, this.
These look terrible.
I just wish the design
was a bit better.
I'm going to be taking it out
in one minute.
That's it, whatever happens,
happens.
DAN GROANS
How long have we got left?
Bakers, you have one
minute remaining.
These are going to have to come out.
What a mess.
Oh, dear!
Bakers, your time is up.
Rubbish.
That's so disappointing.
My fault entirely.
Please bring your ma'amouls and
place them behind your photo
on the table!
I made ma'amoul!
Does anyone want any?!
Paul and Prue are looking
for 12 beautifully baked pastries
with the perfect balance of spices -
six filled with date,
six with walnut.
But as they judge,
they have no idea which bakers
have made which ma'amouls.
Right, we'll start down here.
The walnut - they have split,
you see some of the filling
coming through.
Although, the bake looks OK.
It's quite potent. Too potent? Yeah.
Right, let's have a look at
the date.
Slightly deflated balls!
Some taste of dates. That's spicy.
It's too strong.
I think they've gone slightly
overboard there with the flavours.
Moving on to number two. Not much
decoration on the date one again.
It's more like a flat biscuit
than a ball. OK.
I like the pastry.
The bitterness, is that the...?
Mastica. Mastica.
Yeah. A bit too much.
This has had serious,
serious problems with the pastry.
It's just falling to pieces.
I think it's got too hot
and the oil came out.
But there's no definition in this
at all.
That's poor pastry.
Nice flavour, though.
OK, now moving on.
There's no pattern on this.
Not much filling either,
is there?
Mmm.
Nice. It's good, that. Delicious.
There is definition on this one.
There is.
You can see it on the walnut
and you can see all the ridges.
It's quite well baked.
You get that floral hint
coming from the rose water.
I think that's pretty good.
So obviously you can see the filling
coming through in this.
This is meant to be the walnut
one. They've got the wrong shape.
It is a little over-baked.
It's quite dry, isn't it? Yeah.
Wrong shape, very dry,
filling coming through.
Right, a good bit
of definition here. Neat.
Icing sugar on all of them.
You're only meant to ice
the walnut one.
The pastry and the flavours are
good. Quite delicate, the spices.
Yeah. They're not so potent.
And even again, fairly uniform.
It's just a shame none of them have
got the real shape on the top.
Let's start with the walnut.
Buttery pastry.
I love that filling.
It's almost toffee-like.
Right, moving on to the last one.
There is a nice definition actually
in the walnut one
where you see the little flower
coming through on the top.
The flavour's good,
the pastry's good.
A very good filling.
NOEL: Paul and Prue must now rank
the ma'amouls from worst to best.
OK, in ninth place is this one.
Whose is this? It's mine.
Karen, the wrong way around. Yeah.
In eighth place we have this one.
Oh, Terry, a bit of a mess,
weren't they?
I must have put too much ghee in
because the pastry melted off them.
John is seventh, Briony sixth,
Manon fifth,
and in fourth place Kim-Joy.
In third spot is this one.
Rahul. Not bad at all.
You did have some definition
on the walnut ones.
It just comes down to neatness.
And then we have in second place...
..this one. Dan.
Quite good definition
but not on all of them,
but the flavour was fantastic.
So in first place...
THEY CHEER
The pastry and the flavours together
were very good. Well done.
Thank you. Well done, Ruby.
Me! You're so good at this.
I mean, what?!
I mean... I just... What?!
Happy days because the Signature
was, like, a shocker.
So, yeah, relieved because
I feel that sort of pulled me
back to the middle.
Not happy about that one.
I just thought,
"It's Spice Week, let's go for it."
And I killed it.
I didn't come last,
I think it should have come last.
Yeah, that was just a disaster!
They looked so...
Well, everything felt right
until they went in the oven.
To pull anything back from this,
I've got to have a corking
great Showstopper tomorrow.
One Spice Week challenge remains,
and the bakers face a day
in the tent like no other.
So, our lovely Prudence
under the weather this morning -
I'm gonna blame those spices
yesterday.
You seem fine, though.
I've got the constitution
of a rhino.
Yeah, she's a bit under the weather
today,
so I'll be flying solo.
What you're looking at,
at the moment, for Star Baker
is Rahul, Manon, Kim-Joy.
And I also would have to put Ruby
in there, mainly because
she won the Technical.
There are two people who are in
a very precarious position -
Karen and Terry.
Briony has to be introduced
to that, as well.
Dan and Jon, at the moment,
are very much in the middle.
But having a bad day today
would naturally bring them down to
the bottom and put them in
a little bit of trouble.
God, you're handsome.
I was just thinking that. Yeah.
I'm on the turn. You, too.
We're both on the turn now.
Morning, bakers, and welcome
to your Showstopper Challenge.
Unfortunately, Prue is not
with us this morning.
But that doesn't mean it's going
to be any easier for you.
Now it's just bad cop, bad cop.
Yeah, so...
Paul would like you to make
a spiced biscuit chandelier.
It must be a breathtakingly
beautiful, deliciously fragrant,
edible spiced biscuit structure,
that can be hung as a centrepiece
over a table.
The flavour and type of biscuit
is entirely up to you.
You have four hours.
On your marks...
Get set... Bake!
Oh! It does make me nervous
that it's just Paul judging today.
Yeah.
This is the grandest challenge
of the competition so far.
The bakers must perfect huge batches
of deliciously spiced biscuits...
Ground cinnamon.
..plus design spectacular structures
strong enough to hang them from.
We've had biscuit challenges before.
I've seen the Colosseum in biscuit.
But this is slightly different,
they're all built
from the bottom up.
We're asking for something
to be built from the top down.
This is slightly unusual.
This is all about spiced biscuit,
and there's loads of things
they could use -
cardamom, cinnamon, nutmeg.
I want that gorgeous feeling of
warmth that comes from the spice.
Now, although the chandelier's
got to be pretty robust,
if they over-bake,
it's going to be too hard.
Or if they under-bake their biscuit,
chances are it's gonna collapse.
Could be making upwards of
50, 60, 100 biscuits.
So, again, consistency throughout
it all and perfection, obviously.
Good morning. Good morning.
Right, tell us all about
your biscuit chandelier.
What are you doing? The spices are -
possibly controversially -
liquorice and cardamom.
I love liquorice.
Karen's future in the competition
rests on her highly unusual
liquorice and cardamom biscuits,
which will be hung in tribute
to her old school friends
back in her hometown.
Pontefract is where, traditionally,
we've grown liquorice.
And I went to
a Pontefract girls' school.
The uniform was brown.
We used to be called
the Brown Knicker Girls.
The Brown Knicker Girls?
I think that's too much information.
Is that because of the liquorice?
No!
Whichever spice they've chosen,
the balance of ingredients
in their biscuit dough
could ruin the bakers' chances
in this final challenge.
It's not the easiest thing to make
biscuits hang, funnily enough.
Too much butter and the biscuits
may crumble before they can be held.
I think it's quite sticky.
Too much sugar and they'll be
so brittle, the components of
their chandeliers will crack,
destroying their Showstoppers.
I'm putting marshmallow and things
in there, I think I can afford
to go a little bit more crispy
on the biscuit.
The main thing is structure on this,
I don't want it falling apart.
Jon's hoping to pull clear
of trouble with
a marshmallow and raspberry
chilli jam filled cinnamon biscuit.
It's his second family themed
bake of Spice Week.
For my daughter's 21st birthday,
I thought I would do this for her.
She loves cinnamon.
Jon's daughter won't be
the only one celebrating with
a cinnamon chandelier.
I thought it'd be a fun thing to do
for, like, a kids' birthday party.
My daughter will be turning six,
so it's pink and purple
and butterflies and very girly.
Constance will celebrate
her sixth birthday
with flying butterfly-shaped
cinnamon biscuits,
ornately decorated with apple icing.
Apple itself, you're not gonna
really taste that in an icing.
So it's made with apple juice
and I'm boosting it a little bit
with a bit out of a bottle.
When you're adding icing, it also
affects the texture of a biscuit,
and it's gonna be hanging.
It's a ridiculous idea.
No offence, Paul.
Hang on a minute, hang on a minute.
Are you saying that the challenge
itself is a ridiculous idea?
I wouldn't start there, Dan.
If you do an internet search
for biscuit chandelier,
do you know what comes up?
Nothing. Nothing.
Exactly, that's why it was chosen.
Three more bakers are
celebrating a special occasion.
But for their Showstoppers,
Christmas has come early.
I imagine this at a Christmas party
with people picking off biscuits
as they're chilling
and doing whatever.
Kim-Joy's bid for her first
Star Baker crown has seen her add
extra nutmeg and cinnamon
to her Christmas biscuits,
shaped as snowflakes and featuring
intricately iced festive scenes.
Time is the biggest factor.
For hanging biscuits, I'm making 28.
So, not too many, cos I want
to decorate them quite a bit.
Yes!
Manon is also throwing
a Christmas party.
Mine would be like
a Great Gatsby style party.
So, I went for Art Deco style.
Her Art Deco chandelier
will feature
chocolate and tonka bean
checkerboards,
inspired by her Christmases
back in France.
Every year at Christmas, my mum
and dad get this amazing chocolate
from a chocolatier.
And he always uses so many different
spices and I think that's
from there that
I've learned about tonka.
So, yeah, I went with it.
Hoping to avoid leaving the tent...
My dough has become very wet.
..Terry is throwing the biggest
Christmas party he can.
My chandelier is a Christmas
chandelier based on the song,
The 12 Days of Christmas. OK.
Characters 12, 11, ten, nine,
eight, seven, six...
That's a lot.
78 characters.
You've got your work cut out.
I have. Cut out literally
with a cut-out. But, yeah!
As well as taking on 12 verses,
Terry's baking two flavours
of biscuit - a cinnamon,
clove and pepper,
and an allspice and vanilla.
And he plans to decorate all 78.
It's all about timing.
I know. It really is.
Try and rein it in today, Terry.
Yeah, I'm down to my
maids a-milking now,
so onto number eight.
It's a great sentence -
"I'm down to my maids a-milking."
What you doing? Well, with Prue
not here to interpret,
we're gonna have to learn
to speak Paul.
Oh, good point. What you got?
"Narky - state of anger
and irritation."
Perfect. Bakers, you've had
one hour, you have three hours left.
If baking huge quantities
of different sized biscuits
wasn't complicated enough...
So, the colour it goes in initially,
it's always dark.
So it's quite hard to tell,
and sometimes they look
a little bit burnt.
..the bakers will now have
to start planning
the large biscuit structures
that they hope will support them.
So, this is what my dangly bits
will hang off of.
Whilst they can use materials
to strengthen them...
Perspex holds much better
than just plain biscuit.
..they must be invisible
and covered in biscuit.
My sister said, "You're a trained
architect, you should know
"about the structure."
Erm, no, love.
Ruby's peacock themed chandelier
will need to support the weight
of 50 pistachio
and cardamom biscuits,
sandwiched with a thick raspberry
and white chocolate ganache.
My only query is because it's quite
warm today... Quite warm, yeah.
..and you're using a ganache base,
which is chocolate,
if that softens, it will drop.
Oh! I didn't think of that.
It'll be fine. I actually left it
hanging overnight
and it was fine. There you go.
So...
Where did you do that, though?
At home.
In a freezer. In a freezer! Iceland.
With supports and everything.
I hung it up overnight to see
if it would hold and it did,
so I'm hoping it'll be
all right today.
But you never know cos in the tent,
everything's completely different.
Making it to the next round will
mean Briony's structure will support
40 highly decorated biscuits
with mixed spice, clove,
and an Eastern kick straight
from her local coffee shop.
So, I am doing a turmeric latte
biscuit chandelier.
Just when I thought this couldn't
get weirder. I know, right?
It's a really nice flavour.
It's quite unusual.
And are you ever going to get
the turmeric stains off you?
I look so ill after I make these!
My mum's like, "Are you all right?"
I'm like, "Yeah, don't worry,
"it's just turmeric."
I hope it's going to look like
a chandelier.
That's the whole plan.
Rahul is also heading East.
Mine is for a Durga Puja party.
It's like a worshipping of
this ultimate goddess,
mother goddess or something.
Rahul will celebrate
the Hindu festival of Durga Puja,
with a structure that
must support six hanging rows
of individually decorated and
filled orange and cardamom biscuits.
How many biscuits?
I'm making about 150 biscuits.
What? Yeah. I know, I'm crazy.
150 biscuits? Yeah.
I know, I'm crazy.
I'm just going to try my best
and see as far as I can go.
OK, good luck.
What do you think of the judging?
Ah, nobody will know the difference.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
You always think there's plenty
of time and there never is.
It just seems to... evaporate!
Oh, that needs to come out the oven,
doesn't it?
Yep, they're done.
That is just starting to colour,
so it's good.
Where am I going to put it now?
Oh, my gosh.
Just need to get those cooled.
Damage.
It's puffed up a little bit.
They've got, like,
a crack along the top.
It's such a weird thing.
I've lost count. Genuinely lost
count of how many biscuits
I've got going on.
SHE SIGHS
This challenge is
about to get even more complicated.
This is the other batch.
With time tight, the bakers will
now have to start decorating
the baked biscuits...
I'm putting some apple juice.
So, I will use some synthetic
assistance - essence in a bottle.
We'll keep that to a minimum.
..while constantly preparing
and baking even more.
I think I'm still behind.
I just hope I'm doing this
as fast as I would at home.
All the icing needs to be set
before the biscuits can be hung.
I'm scared of running out of time
and having nothing decent to show.
Otherwise it will smudge or,
even worse, run off the biscuits.
This is just like
a classic wet-on-wet technique.
Either they dry in time,
or they don't.
Time, I'm just concerned now, I've
got to get some decoration on these.
I've still got
21 little biscuits to make.
It does actually look like I've had
some sort of psychedelic disco.
They look better with decoration,
I promise.
Oh, these are good.
What flavour can you get?
Cardamom.
Oh, that's good. And?
I don't even know what cardamom is.
I just said that. I know that.
NOEL LAUGHS
So this is just to go on the top.
Oh, no!
Just not great.
I'll make this again.
What is burning?
Oh. I think I might
have burnt my biscuits.
Those are rubbish.
Bakers,
you've got half an hour left.
Half an hour to complete
your biscuit chandeliers.
That is not a lot of time.
OK. Showtime.
The bakers now have
the terrifying task of assembling
their delicate chandeliers.
It's a case of making sure
it all hangs equally.
This is just like
icicle, like, drips.
These are gonna have to go up
sooner than I'd like.
Oh, God, I'm shaking.
So quiet, innit? Scary.
I just realised
the biscuits are so soft.
So much pressure.
Keep going, keep going.
Ah!
I would have liked longer
for decoration, but I'll get
something decorated. Did you
get your maids a-milking done?
I did. All my maids are milked.
I don't think you should
milk a maid. No.
I don't know. Not at this point.
No.
Oh, no. Just looking rubbish now.
Argh!
I don't know what the hell
has gone wrong with these.
The biscuits are breaking
as I'm pushing them down.
I'm just sandwiching the biscuits.
SHE SIGHS
It's just not thick enough.
The ganache has let me down,
it just wouldn't hold.
Right, not getting sandwiched.
There's nothing else
I can do about it.
Bakers, you have...
Five minutes left!
Ah!
Just going to be
really tight with time.
Turtle dove broke its neck!
Little girl's dreams,
such a big man piping them. Yeah!
Eight maids milking.
We're down to seven,
one's dropped on the floor.
Finishing touches.
Ah!
This looks so messy.
Four verses to go.
Most of them say "Emily".
Oh, that doesn't.
Bottom one's a bit of a mess,
but never mind.
She's on, she's off, she's on.
Bakers...
..your time is up.
Please step away from
your biscuit chandeliers.
Pff!
There are biscuit chandeliers
in this room! Yeah, there are!
I didn't think there would be one!
You're so annoying.
What did I do now?
You're so annoyingly good.
Come on, Ruby, you can't say
that to me.
It's judgment time for
the spiced biscuit chandeliers.
Manon, please will you
bring up your Showstopper?
Ah, this is a delicate business!
NOEL: What could go wrong?
I think it looks amazing.
Thank you.
I think the detailing round the top
is very good, but what's impressive
is the fact that you've given it all
the same shade all the way down.
Now, the chequerboard effect, did
you build it all up and then chop...
BISCUIT CRASHES ONTO TABLE
Yes. Oops!
And then...
Wow, we're under attack.
It's all about the spice, for me,
and I'm not getting much in the
way of massive amounts of flavour,
which I would have expected.
But as the biscuit goes and the
design, it's very, very impressive.
The pattern on the butterflies
is exquisite.
But what does it taste like?
I don't get any cinnamon
in that biscuit.
All the flavour
comes from the icing,
which is almost a synthetic flavour
that I'm getting.
They were meant to be sandwiched,
but unfortunately, with the heat,
as you suggested, it wouldn't stay.
Pistachio's lost, but the cardamom
in there's delicious.
It's a beautifully baked biscuit.
Thank you.
Rahul, please bring up
your chandelier.
NOEL: Don't drop that, please.
I think what you've done
is beautiful.
I think the colours are amazing.
You've got the sugarwork inside
there as well, which is fantastic.
It's a bit messy in places. It's
almost like time was against you
all the way. How many biscuits
did you make? 150?
The flavour of that cardamom,
the way it melts in the mouth,
the butter in the biscuit
is beautiful.
You've even got the bit of blossom,
that little hint at the back,
as well. It's a fantastic biscuit.
You need to pull something back,
cos it's nearly there.
It's just a little bit messy
in places.
The biscuits look solid,
you know, chunky.
We're big girls in Pontefract.
THEY LAUGH
Still are! Sorry!
What's weird is the liquorice
and cardamom together
taste like ginger!
Liquorice is one of those flavours
that has to be quite pure
to come through.
I'm curious about
the texture of this biscuit.
It's almost got a skin on the top.
Yeah, it's kind of cracked, yeah.
Yeah. I've never seen
anything like it. Oh!
OK, well, I hope you like it!
Mixed spice,
a little bit of clove...
Turmeric?
Possibly.
It is unusual. I've never had
a biscuit like that before. OK.
Kim-Joy, would you like to bring up
your spiced biscuit chandelier?
Well, that is exquisite. Ah!
Your piping is phenomenal.
These little biscuits
down the bottom,
I mean, look at the detail on that.
It's absolutely gorgeous.
I love the little icicles
with the ice melt, as well.
Very, VERY clever.
Thank you.
The spices you've got in there
really work together.
It's a classic
Christmas combination.
Have you got a bit of nutmeg
in there, as well? Oh, yeah, nutmeg.
Got a lovely warmth to it.
That is very, very well
thought through.
Thank you so much!
It was stunning.
Did you finish it?
Did you get it all done? No. No.
The biscuits look quite dark,
some of them.
This tree at the bottom
looks a bit...
Black. Yeah. Run by
the flavours again for me.
There's cinnamon,
mixed allspice and black pepper.
It's quite bland. Really?
Considering what you put in there,
all the spices and the pepper,
I expected it to be full of flavour,
and it just isn't. Mm-hm.
The maids here are
a slightly different biscuit?
Not getting it, again. No?
I think the idea was very good.
And you've got a lot
of the detail on there,
but I think you took on
far too much. Yeah.
Jon, would you like to bring up
your biscuit chandelier, please?
It's a bit messy. It is, very. It
feels like it needs finishing off.
As far as the flavour goes,
the cinnamon is the king there.
It is like a shortbread. It's such
a delicate, buttery biscuit.
If I was blindfolded, it would have
been fantastic. Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Cheers. Thanks, Jon.
Right, my lovely bakers, nothing
left for you to do while Paul has
to decide who is the Star Baker and
who are the two people who are going
to be leaving us this week.
That's, like, nine down to seven.
It's just such a big jump, you know?
I'd like to think that I did well.
But, yeah, I don't know.
Paul's very diplomatic -
a gentleman, I think.
Very kind, actually.
I can bake better than that.
Hopefully, with the flavours
in my biscuit, it'll keep me
through to Week Six, cos that's
all I'm hoping for at the moment!
Clearly, I'm one of them.
I am going home. Of course!
You've lost your double act
partner. How was it for you?
I missed Prue, actually, today.
I missed her, there's too much
testosterone at this table.
What, from you and Paul? Yeah.
SANDI CHUCKLES
So, the Showstopper.
Has that shifted things
dramatically?
I think when it comes to Star Baker,
I think Rahul is in the running.
Again. His biscuit, unbe...
I mean, it melted in the mouth.
You have to put Kim-Joy
in the mix for Star Baker,
because that Showstopper was superb.
Karen and Terry were struggling a
little bit
coming into the
Showstopper. Still struggling?
There was no real spice
coming through.
Briony did quite well. Yeah.
She saved herself?
It was a strange one.
She used a lot of different
spices, didn't she?
She did, and I think, probably, if
I'm honest, too many.
I will put Jon in there as well.
It was a bit all over the place
and a bit messy.
As Prue's not here, did you want our
help? Cos we could, we could
absolutely help you make your
decision.
No. OK.
That's a no. I think that's a no.
Is that a no?
Well done, bakers, that's the end of
the very first ever spice week,
and what a fragrant success
you made of it.
This week I have the great
job of announcing
Star Baker.
And it was quite tight.
But the Star Baker this week is...
..Kim-Joy.
CHEERING AND APPLAUSE
So I get the rotten job, I'm afraid.
It's a really unusual week,
we are sending home two people.
And the two people who will be
leaving the tent...
..are Karen and Terry.
Yes, well...
It's all right. Thank you.
No problem.
Sorry, love. Hey.
It was great to get halfway through.
What a crazy, crazy
few weeks I've had here.
Yeah.
Outside of having your family,
as a personal achievement,
nothing will ever top this,
I don't think, obviously.
You did really well, mate.
You're a gentleman.
I said I wouldn't get upset.
Um...
It's funny when you're on your own.
Thank you!
My wife and I were very happy.
And that was a massive loss.
And there wasn't anything that
filled that void for a long time,
so it did give me a focus.
I'll miss you. I'm gonna miss you.
I've met some lovely people.
I'm sure we'll keep in touch
for a long time.
Yeah. It's been a big help.
HE COUGHS
Sorry, it's been a big help.
And, um...
..one I'll remember for a long time.
I'm gonna miss you!
I won't stop baking, I'm very much
looking forward to
more adventurous projects...
..carried out in a
bigger time frame.
No baking for a bit.
I'm going away in the caravan.
Well done. Good job.
So happy!
I was hoping, hoping, hoping and it
happened and I'm over the moon.
It's not the week that I'd
expect it to happen -
spice week -
when my flavours have been a bit...
But it makes me feel like
I've learned things.
It's so nice, but then
I feel like maybe
the pressure's on for next week, and
I'm going to have to practise a lot.
Next week...
..pastry is on the menu.
Mix, mix, mix, mix, mix.
The signature gets
temperatures sizzling.
Damn it, damn it, damn it.
Hearts flare up for a
technical all about love.
How has this happened to me?
And the bakers shape up
showstopping banquet pies
as we enter the final half...
Sack it, I'm doing it.
..of the Great British Bake Off.
I'm too, like,
embarrassed to take mine out.
Oh, man.
Subtitles by Red Bee Media